bereits mehrfach hat die afg im
bundestag den versuch unternommen den
vize-präsidenten aus den eigenen reihen
wählen zu lassen
mit der mehrheit der anderen parteien
ist dies immer wieder verhindert worden
die reaktion der afg war massiv die
abgeordneten drohen mit totalblockade es
ist ja so dass wir im bundestag
kontroverse themen diskutieren deswegen
sind wir alle hier und dafür sind die
debatten da und das kann auch mal hitzig
werden und das kann auch rhetorisch
werden und da kann auch mal austausch
stattfinden aber was wir doch bitte
nicht machen dass wir uns verleumderisch
begegnen und behaupten wir hätten hier
hätten gesagt wir wollten den
parlamentsbetrieb hier behindern
systematisch oder sonstwie haben genau
das gegenteil wir sagt wir werden das
nicht machen
sie haben dauern wir werden das nicht
machen was wir machen
wir setzen die wahlen auf für den vize
präsidenten der uns zusteht silenen
kandidat off kandidat ab wir stellen
neue zur wahl das kostet wertvolle zeit
dem bundestag hier wo eigentlich
debatten stattfinden sollten sie
behinderte parlamentsbetrieb in dem sie
sechs millionen wähler draußen und ihr
eingewählt haben verhindern dass wir
entsprechende vize-präsidenten hier
kriegen sie behindern aber woraus in
erster linie antwort hört sie mit den
verleumdung auf sagen sie wer das gesagt
haben soll von uns dass wir das
behindern wollen systematisch frau
steffen sie haben gelogen sagen sie
welche quellen sie haben oder schweigen
sie still frau kollegin
frau kollegin wollen sie dazu antworten
bitte schön sonja steffen ich lasse mir
von ihnen mit sicherheit nicht den mund
verbieten dass ihre dass ihre kandidaten
nicht gewählt werden ist demokratie da
müssen sie sich mit abfinden wie geht es
für team parlament so und jetzt zu den
zitat es mein zitat war wörtlich
entnommen der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung von der aktuellen
ausgabe schauen sie da rein und jetzt
sage ich ihnen noch ein wörtliches zitat
von ihnen augenblick genau hegau landtag
gesagt ich zitiere wörtlich wenn man
krieg haben wir in diesem bundestag kann
man krieg bekommen und das gehört sich
wirklich nicht gut ist ein weiterer
versuch gescheitert
und der ärger ist wieder groß die afg
führte studiert abgegebene stimmzettel
635 ungültige stimmzettel einer mit ja
haben gestimmt 210 abgeordnete mit nein
haben gestimmt 323 abgeordnete 31
enthaltungen
der abgeordnete gerold otten hat die
erforderliche mehrheit von mindestens 3
155 stimmen nicht erreicht
er ist zum stellvertreter des
präsidenten somit nicht gewählt die
reaktion der afg auf die heutige
abstimmung haben wir auch zusammen
gefasst es beginnt der gescheiterte
vizepräsident gerd ordnung
die anderen parteien im bundestag setzen
ihre obstruktionspolitik vor dieses
undemokratische ausgrenzen der afd
wir sehen auch von den ergebnissen dass
also völlig unabhängig ist welchen
kandidaten wir aufstellen das sind immer
in der gleichen größe und die stimme
ergebnisse bedauere dass weiterhin dass
hier unsere wähler nicht repräsentiert
sind im bundestagspräsidium ich werde
mich selbstverständlich auch wie schon
angekündigt wieder dem nächsten wahlgang
stellen wie sagt freddie frinton so
schön im dinner for one
same procedure as every year und wir
werden unseren kandidaten noch einmal
aufstellen da muss der ältestenrat
zustimmen
und wir werden dadurch belegen dass es
eben die alten zu recht gesagt überhaupt
nicht mehr personen geht sondern jeder
kandidat von uns wird abgelehnt
wir könnten euch will mir jetzt nicht
irgendeine figur nennen die auf jeden
fall aufgestellt werden könnte wenn er
von uns kommt wird nicht gewählt und
genau das ist das was am ende nicht geht
und das müssen wir dann am ende auch vom
verfassungsgericht feststellen lassen
mir persönlich fällt auch zu dieser
posse gar nichts mehr ein also von daher
kann ich auch dazu nichts weiter sagen
ja volker kronenberg das geht schon ein
bisschen anders zu den deutschen
bundestag inzwischen halten sie es denn
grundsätzlich für klug dass die parteien
außer der afg versuchen die afg und ihre
vize präsidentschaft sozusagen zu
blockieren
nein halte ich nicht für klug aber
interessant ist ja auch herr und es
entwickelt sich etwas bewegt sich denn
es sind hier nicht mehr die parteien die
fraktionen geschlossen sondern wir
beobachten ja interessanterweise dass
beispielsweise der
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende sich daher
jetzt schon anders positioniert dann als
große teile seiner fraktion oder
christian lindner das heißt das ganze
bild durchmischt sich und das hier zu
einem wandel auch kommt in der
einstellung und auch in der empfehlung
eben jetzt doch eine solche wahl zu
ermöglichen hat sicherlich auch damit zu
tun dass regeln und es gibt nunmal
regeln ist nicht das grundgesetz ist
aber die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages regeln gelten für alle die
fdp-fraktion seine starke fraktion mann
gehört dazu regeln hören für alle und
letztendlich ist es ja so auch aus sicht
jetzt der partei mannschaft ja immer
wieder die möglichkeit auch für die
fdp-fraktion sich in einer opferrolle zu
begeben es ist immer wieder
öffentlichkeit die generiert wird und
wir dürfen nicht vergessen irgendwann in
der bevölkerung in der öffentlichkeit
ist ja die frage wieso denn eigentlich
nicht wieso wird denn jeder man kann ja
bei einzelpersonen völlig zu recht
bedenken haben und dann eine nichtwahl
sich dazu entscheiden aber grundsätzlich
zu sagen das kommt nicht infrage obwohl
sie demokratisch gewählt ist die
fraktion regeln gelten für alle
das wird auf dauer auch nicht
durchzuhalten sein in meinen augen
demokratie wissenschaftlich nicht klug
gehe auf die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages hat das pro oder macht es
probleme für die geschäftsordnung des
bundestags
es macht keine probleme sie sieht das
vor bis zu drei wahlgänge pro kandidat
und immer wieder muss der ältestenrat
letztendlich dann auch einstimmig sich
positionieren ich will sagen die
geschäftsordnung sieht auch so etwas vor
man kann das im grunde immer weiter
perpetuieren bedürfen nur ja nicht
vergessen er ist hat natürlich solche
debatten gerade wenn parteien neu ins
parlament kam er wieder gegeben als die
grünen 83 das erst mal in den bundestag
kam haben die grünen auch kein vize
präsidentin stellen können übrigens bis
1994 da hat wolfgang schäuble das auch
seit sich der union ermöglicht das
eigentliche vollmer erstmals 490 nach
elf jahren ein solches amt antreten
konnte das ging dann zu lasten damals
eines zweiten vizepräsidenten postens
der spd und bei der linken klappte das
am anfang auch nicht bisky wurde nicht
welt später brauche ich will sagen immer
wieder wenn neu dazukommen dann gibt es
natürlich weniger zu verteilen auch
anfreunden für die alten dann ist
natürlich unruhe da auch parlamentarisch
lebhaft alles und die gehören nicht dazu
und die werden auch nur kurz dabei sein
der ändern nicht die regeln aber
letztendlich sie haben nach der
geschäftsordnung gefragt dafür gibt es
regeln und geschäftsordnungen sind
erstmal einzuhalten oder mit mehrheit
auch änderbar aber wenn man etwas ändert
die spielregeln dann muss man das sehr
sehr gut begründen
wir müssen trotzdem noch mal vielleicht
über die politischen folgen sprechen sie
haben gesagt wenn man das zu oft macht
von den anderen partei
dann bekommt die afg sozusagen klein
bonus dadurch egal was da passiert hat
sie auch ein bonus dadurch dass sie das
parlament insgesamt ein bisschen stärker
auf mischt es sind ja auch äußerungen
dabei die nun ja immer mal wieder fallen
im übrigen auch in den letzten
jahrzehnten aber die vielleicht auch ein
bisschen sehr drastisch von ornament
sind ja und das ist natürlich gar nicht
ausgemacht sie haben völlig recht gar
nicht ausgemacht ob die rechnung dann
aufgeht das ist ja kalkulierte
provokation das ist natürlich auch die
strategie sie die auf dem muster
auffallen sie will er provozieren sie
will ja diese opposition immer gegen
widerspruch dass fundamentale das droht
natürlich mit der zeit über im monate
jahre auch zu erlahmen das ganze man
muss ja die eskalationsspirale
rhetorisch dann auch immer weiter
zuspitzen ich würde sagen das ist auch
kein selbstläufer für die afg natürlich
nicht aber jetzt mal wieder umgekehrt
wir sprachen über diese opferrolle in
der sie sich da ein stück weit auch
sonnen kann es sicherlich aus sicht des
parlamentarismus demokratie lebt von der
kraft des arguments und nicht sozusagen
über so tricks dann nicht wählen sondern
man sollte sich an die spielregeln
halten und die anderen parteien sind
klug beraten argumentativ offensiv wir
sind unmittelbar vor einer europawahl
es geht um europa wäre neben dem break
sind andere wichtige fragen die afg ist
da überaus kritisch und grenzt sich da
von den anderen ab ja dann soll man doch
in der sache die partei stellen offensiv
argumentieren und nicht über solche
winkelzüge das ist letztlich auch nicht
stark für die anderen parteien wird
letztlich auf dauer auch in der
bevölkerung nicht wirklich überzeugen
professor kohlenberg ganz herzlichen
dank für diese einschätzung